[Música]
y
este 21 de septiembre día internacional
de la paz colombia está a punto de
conmemorar cuatro años desde la firma de
los acuerdos de paz entre el gobierno
colombiano y la guerrilla de las farc
fue el 26 de septiembre de 2016 carlos
ruiz massieu o el representante especial
de las naciones unidas en colombia
aseguró que el día internacional de la
paz es siempre una oportunidad para que
colombia forge la paz en unión en este
sentido en plena pandemia las naciones
unidas ya habían pedido un alto el fuego
global algo que en colombia no se ha
cumplido este 2020 el país está viviendo
un año violento con al menos 60 masacres
y 244 asesinados en plena
reconfiguración del conflicto armado un
conflicto de más de 50 años que en enero
registraba más de 8,5 millones de
víctimas
precisamente este 21 de septiembre se
celebra un paro nacional en colombia con
las masacres como uno de los motivos
principales de protesta en este día
internacional de la paz
[Música]
conmemoramos el día internacional de la
paz desde la plaza de los nobel en
ciudad del cabo es una plaza que rinde
tributo a los cuatro premios nobel de
paz que ha tenido sudáfrica y entre los
avances por la paz en el continente cabe
destacar el acuerdo en sudán que ha
tenido lugar en las últimas semanas es
un acuerdo entre el gobierno sudanés y
una coalición de grupos rebeldes del sur
del país llamado el frente
revolucionario de sudán son los grupos
que solían operar durante 17 años de
conflicto en el sur del país sobre todo
en la región de darfur que es bien
conocida por la profundidad de su crisis
humanitaria y por el gran número de
desplazados internos que registraron de
las cifras más altas del mundo y el
acuerdo incluye un proceso de justicia
transicional así como el regreso de
miles de desplazados que han tenido que
ver de sus casas por el conflicto y este
es un paso significativo para la
democracia ciudadana así como lo fue la
caída del dictador omar al-bashir en
2019 pero sudán aún tiene mucho por
recorrer en cuanto a su proceso
democrático por ejemplo en los últimos
días han sido arrestados cinco artistas
en jartúm la capital entre los cuales se
encuentra hay un es cuca un reconocido
cineasta
que trabaja para fomentar la democracia
y los derechos humanos en el país a
través del arte y la cultura
hay un cas un miembro de la academia de
artes y ciencias cinematográficas y se
ha lanzado una campaña internacional en
la industria cinematográfica del mundo
para exigir su pronta liberación
[Música]
en el día internacional de la paz
preocupan los acuerdos de viernes santo
que fueron firmados en la provincia de
irlanda del norte y que ha permitido la
estabilidad en la región en los últimos
20 años en 1998 las divididas
comunidades protestantes y católicas
firmaron el acuerdo de viernes santo que
entre otras cosas logró el desarme de
grupos paramilitares y el retiro de
tropas británicas sin embargo los
expertos advierten que si el gobierno
británico no cumple con el acuerdo del
break sí que ha firmado con la unión
europea se podría poner en riesgo este
acuerdo de paz en particular en lo que
respecta a una frontera invisible que
existe entre irlanda del norte e irlanda
estar frontera invisible permite
diariamente el libre flujo de personas y
de bienes y productos
[Música]